and we're here another year of the Apple
event it is the iPhone 15. it is iPhone
season friends let's get into it wait
wait wait before we get into it I've got
a pack packing for these events is the
most difficult part but I am so excited
this year to be bringing along some new
accessories from anchor thanks to anchor
for partnering with me on this video
with the new iPhone 15s being USBC this
new lineup of chargers by anchor are
just what we need first up we have the
nano power bank it's a 30 watt fast
charger you can charge your iPhone 15 to
50 percent in 30 minutes it has a 10 000
milliamp hour capacity and this little
Loop right here oh guess what this is a
built-in USBC cable it's got two
additional ports on the side for
charging additional devices I also love
that it has an LCD right here with
charging information right on the front
and now this is the nano power bank
which is a 22.5 watt charger 5000
milliamp hour capacity with two USB
ports and this pop-up USBC port to plug
directly into the bottom of your new
iPhone 15. this entire collection also
comes in five colorful finishes now this
is something I won't be leaving home
without when I travel a mini portable
power station with a 67 watt USBC fast
charger two USBC two usba and two AC
power options my favorite part about
this is how slim and Sleek it is now to
plug in I also have this matching anchor
20 watt Nano charger and color
coordinated USBC cable that comes in
Three 6 and 10 foot sizes even though I
don't have the iPhone 15 yet with all of
these devices I'm going to be powered up
and ready to go to cover the event
and officially packed in the car into
the airport we have made it this is
shocking I'm only staying in Cupertino
for two nights and my luggage is 57
pounds what anyway we all know I have a
packing problem I headed to the AmEx
Lounge to get a little dinner they had a
wide selection of treats I am a little
upset they didn't have any mac and
cheese so I ended up with some sort of
fake chicken salad and some rice thing
it was actually quite good it's nearing
boarding time so I gathered up all of my
heavy items and headed to my gate but
not before passing this gaming station
like what is this well I know if I ever
have a delayed flight that's where I'll
be hanging out the flight went well no
issues we gotta love a good Biscoff on
the Delta beautiful Skies beautiful
sceneries and then we landed in San Jose
normally I never check a bag when I go
to Apple events because I'm never sure
if I have to change a flight last second
so having carry-ons is always best but
this time I had to bring lights I had to
bring a ton of stuff so unfortunately I
had to check a bag bags acquired let's
get to the home Hotel so I made it now
time to unpack and get things ready for
tomorrow because tomorrow is the big day
after all
[Music]
good morning it is the day of the Apple
event uh I still need to brush my hair
out but I'm gonna go down and get some
breakfast and then prep our gear for the
day doing a bad job of my Vlog so far I
didn't film the beginning of my
breakfast but I filmed the end
Apple Park is just such an incredible
place there's always so much energy and
it's always so exciting when you get
there and see all the Apple logos and
all of the employees and everyone
cheering you on as you enter the event
right now we're all gathered in the
Steve Jobs theater waiting to go
downstairs where the actual keynote
happens this is the best part though
because you run into so many friends and
you see so many people that you haven't
seen since the last event even though
I've been in this building so many times
the architecture still is just so
breathtaking every time I walk down
these stairs it's like I'm walking down
them for the first time at the bottom is
the Steve Jobs theater where the keynote
happens we all rush to find our seat
before the event starts it's interesting
because this is where the Live Events
used to happen but now most of them are
pre-recorded which I actually kind of
prefer it is nice because Tim Cook will
come on stage a few minutes before the
Keynotes and does the introduction and
introduces us all to the Keynotes where
we watch live tweets live X and update
all of our audiences is fast as we can
with all of the latest info this is the
craziest part of the event
of the event line forever the peak bone
is here so let's let's get a first look
there it is
the new pink iPhone 15. look at that
I mean it's absolutely beautiful and
let's not forget it now has USBC
if you've never been to an event like
this before it gets so chaotic because
every journalist content creator
influencer reporter anchor host anyone
who's here at the event is all trying to
get that first shot of the new iPhone
the Apple watch because all of the items
are here for us to check out it's always
super special to see all of the Apple
Executives that you see on stage here
hanging out with us answering questions
and of course sometimes taking selfies
thanks Tim so good to see you
congratulations
I'm smiling so hard like my cheeks hurt
foreign
[Music]
that my favorite color is pink and guess
what it is here it's official we finally
have a beautiful new pink iPhone now
we've had pink in the past this actually
looks so much better in person in the
keynote it looked kind of a really pale
pink now it's pale but the way that they
did this new way of coloring the glass
like it seriously is so awesome it's
like a matte finish too I'm so excited
love to USBC it
now moving into the pro version it comes
in this beautiful titanium color these
are the two colors that I was really
loving this left one is the natural and
the one on the right is the white color
I think the natural is the color that
I'm gonna go with this year and it does
match the titanium Apple watch so
that'll be nice to have both of those
matching
it's been such a busy day
so much fun I had back-to-back briefings
we had the Hands-On events and now I'm
heading to record a podcast in the Apple
podcast studio and this place is so
awesome it is podcast goals if I do say
so myself
all right this is the podcast Studio I'm
so excited this looks so good check it
out so much inspo
[Music]
I'm standing up all day I'm just like my
back is so stiff I need like a little
apple Fitness Plus yoga time to record I
gotta shoot that intro
actually we gotta shoot the whole video
now all right how's it look Tyler looks
really nice nice I'm almost fully
charged hey guys it's Justine and we are
at Cupertino right now
oh my gosh this is my favorite part of
the day where we've filmed all day and
now at this point my batteries are dead
my phone my computer everything is dead
so my favorite thing about this is It's
So flat and compact it has two AC we've
got four USB ports Apple has like a
little anchor station here as well well
I'm I brought my own
[Music]
I cannot wait to use this with the new
iPhone 15. so just picture this I can
just
plug it right into the bottom it's gonna
be so awesome it's actually this also
has a USBC here as well so if you don't
want to use this you can use it like a
tiny little power base all right well
time to edit one of my favorite Parts
about these Apple events are getting to
see other content creators it's so much
work but it's so much fun I love when
the events all over all of my videos are
posted and I get a chance to watch
everyone else's content that they've
posted from the event
well I had to
actually like The Best Day Ever I'd love
to hear from you guys though what is
your favorite thing that Apple announced
today and if you were to get one of the
colorful iPhone 15s which color would
you get if you want to watch more videos
well guess what I've got a ton of them
feel free to click one right here I'd
point but I'm holding things in my hand
and I can't point